the latest details on the Russia
investigation are beginning to make
Watergate look like child's play the
revelations of the Obama era political
targeting grow more ominous by the day
the FBI is under increasing pressure
tonight to explain why it was
surveilling the Trump campaign as the
number of people contacted by informants
continues to increase Sam Clovis George
papadopolis and Carter page were
targeted the latter responding last
night on the angle I never knew anything
about the person I was speaking with
who's a university professor at
Cambridge and in the UK at the time back
I was invited to participate in a
conference in July of 2016 and
everything seemed totally normal
it's called grooming that's what they do
Carter but a much more incendiary claim
was made by one of our other guests
former Trump campaign adviser Michael
Caputo told me last night that he knows
for a fact that there were more than one
was more than one informant targeting
Trump team members because he was one of
those targets let me tell you something
that I know for a fact the this
informant this person that they planted
tried to plant into the campaign and
even into the administration if you
believe Axios he's not the only person
that came at the campaign and the FBI is
not the only Obama agency that came at
the campaign
I know because they came at me the
president responded to the intrigue
today if they had spies in my campaign
that would be a disgrace to this country
that would be one of the biggest insults
that anyone's ever seen and it would be
very illegal aside from everything else
who would make probably every political
event ever look like small potatoes that
would be unprecedented in the history of
our country
Caputo advanced his claim earlier on Fox
claiming that someone I'm a shadowy
figure floated the idea of passing along
emails related to Hillary Clinton to the
Trump campaign just to be clear you
raised this issue with Muller's team
when they
we're questioning you and they did
nothing
they weren't even interested they didn't
even seem to be taking notes I offered
them the time we at the Ingram angle
along with a DOJ producer at Fox looked
into these claims and have identified
the figure in question well our source
corroborated some of Caputo's claims but
he denied trying to entrap Caputo and
his associate he further insisted that
he did not work for any Intelligence
Agency either way it looks like the
FBI's targeting of informal or kind of
low-level Trump associates to get dirt
on higher-ups with something of a trend
perhaps a dangerous one during the Obama
administration let's turn to Newt
Gingrich to react to the latest
revelations about the deep state's
misdeeds mr. speaker it is great to see
you but my goodness this is wild do you
have this is person a professor in
England who's making these contacts that
various members of the Trump team
throwing the whole timeline into
question originally heard from Comey
that it the investigation really began
on July 31st now it looks like this
particular informant spy mole whatever
you want to call him met with Carter
page early July well look at all he
keeps getting more and more open
presently somebody remember there was a
reference at one point very early on two
senior Obama administration people being
briefed presently somebody will figure
out to ask what did Valerie Jared know
and when did she know it I asked that
last night on the end well no and what
did well you're you're right on target
what did Barack Obama know and when did
he know it because what you're seeing
happen is on every single level and this
is what happens with really big scandals
they keep unfolding and they keep
unfolding and they keep unfolding so
we're now supposed to believe that the
Director of National Intelligence was
lying to us the head of the Central
Intelligence Agency was lying to us
the head of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation was lying to
the Deaf number 2 person the FBI was
lying to us the Attorney General was
lying to us come in she was meeting with
Bill Clinton in an airplane in private
to talk about their grandchildren I mean
at what point you just say give me a
break
and all of this I believe was being
coordinated by Obama and by Valerie
Jarrett and by the way you go right to a
bomb on that so you think it's
inconceivable that that could that the
chief executive officer of the country
was not told that they had seen this
Carter page on the list of of the
foreign policy advisers and they decided
to go into you know overdrive look I
don't believe if you took it the total
number of things going on I don't
believe in an administration that was as
tightly centralized as the Obama
administration you could have had as
many different things going on all of
them illegal without the president
having been briefed furthermore give you
another example
the president is emailing Hillary
Clinton on her unsecure email they
carefully reword the FBI report to avoid
telling us that President Obama clearly
had to know she was using an illegal
email because he's writing to it
remember I said President Obama did
everything by the books member she wrote
that email to herself I have to mention
it in every show all right this is what
Jim clapper said today on the view about
whether spying really occurred let's
watch what's the FBI spying on Trump's
campaign no they were not they were
spying on a term I don't particularly
like but on what the Russians were doing
trying to understand were the Russians
infiltrating trying to gain access
trying to gain leverage Newt a
legitimate inquiry if the Russians are
pulling this that's what he says
I know Jim clapper for years I am
astounded how bad he looks now I'm
astounded how dishonest and incompetent
he looks I mean he was a great public
servant for many many years but when the
director of former director national
television tells you he doesn't like to
use the word spying you have to ask that
is funny I didn't
we mentioned that he was the Director of
National Intelligence what do you think
he was in charge of doing he was in
charge of spying yeah and this whole
thing is just the people on the left I
think what happened was people like
clapper and and the former director of
the Central Intelligence Agency all
these guys thought they could get away
with this because Hillary was gonna win
and when Hillary won the fix would be in
everything would be covered up and
around ten o'clock on election night
they all began to realize this could get
really bad and they were shifting gears
from protecting Hillary which had been
their job for two years to trying to
destroy Trump and now you're watching
people who I think in every case or in
danger going to jail I mean if the
system works and people are actually
tested on did you tell the truth under
oath and then clapper is a perfect
example we have actually he was talking
about that big moment where he didn't
tell the truth about the surveillance
program he addressed this today the
president's calling me a lying machine
well okay that stems from is an exchange
I had with senator Wyden five years ago
in March of 2013 about a surveillance
program and he was asking me about one
and I was thinking about another so I
made a mistake but I didn't lie so
that's what occasion though what you're
referencing know is that when you said
when you're talking about James Snowden
blowing the whistle on the NSA illegally
spying and in 2013 when you were asked
about it you said no so that that is a
lie and I'm sorry about one I was
thinking about something else I want to
buy a vowel
no I hope general Flynn watch that yeah
and I think general Flynn is prepared to
go back and say that Muller now
obviously the clapper defense you know
whatever you thought I said I didn't
mean to say and it wasn't what I said
and I don't know why you thought I said
it because I wouldn't have said it if
I'd known you thought I said it and
therefore it can't really be a problem
this I mean this tells you how pathetic
this is good this is the Intelligence
Agency I mean these are like the most
important piece
in our intelligences what you say is
such a good watch it sounds like a
bumbling idiot well what's your watch
I'm being cruel here I guess but that's
just outrageous what you're watching is
a man who was a great professional who's
now in a totally impossible situation
and ought to get off television
desperately trying to explain and defend
the indefensible joy behar look I trust
her more with the national intelligence
at this point then I would Jim clapper
knew